j'adore rigoler puis surtout que bon ici
et là me chambrer quoi c'est tout
pourquoi je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
je suis tt seul joueur qui est bons
acquis par assez vite quoi serait sur
les bêtises des joueurs c'est pour ça
qu'ils aiment bien même allumé après la
dernière que vous ayez fait dernière
pour l'aca la dernière elle va arriver
là bien alors je vais arriver dans
quelques instants sous vos yeux puisque
je crois que je sais pas quelle sera la
victime j'aurais d'abord remercié avant
de vous rendre l'antenne le père quand
port à gérard banide et tous les joueurs
de l'as monaco nous avoir reçu chez eux
aujourd'hui et notre confrère georges
bertellotti qui a largement contribué à
ce que cette émission et lieux et se
déroule dans de bonnes conditions alors
la plaisance parce que bon avec mes
camarades
[Applaudissements]